>>> THE PROBLEMS SURROUNDING
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN GEORGE
SANTOS AND THE LIES THATE HAS
TOLD ABOUT HIS BACKGROUND ARE
PUTTING INCREASING PRESSURE ON
KEY MEMBERS OF HOUSE GOP
LEADERSHIP.
>> CNN CHIEF INVESTIGATIVE
CORRESPONDENT PAMELA BROWN JOINS
US NOW WITH MORE.
SO, ELISE STEFANICK, GOP
CONFERENCE CHAIR NUMBER FOUR IN
THE GOP LEADERSHIP SHOWED
PARTICULAR INTEREST IN THIS
RACE.
>> SHE ABSOLUTELY DID, JIM.
SHE WAS ONE OF SANTOS' BIGGEST
CHEERLEADERS THROUGHOUT THE
CAMPAIGN.
SHE'S THE NUMBER FOUR
REPUBLICAN, AS YOU POINT OUT, IN
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
THE MOST INFLUENTIAL REPUBLICAN
IN HER HOME STATE OF NEW YORK.
A SENIOR REPUBLICAN STRATEGIST
INVOLVED IN THE CAMPAIGNS TOLD
ME, QUOTE, STEFANICK'S TEAM WAS
LASER-FOCUSED ON ELECTING SANTOS
TO CONGRESS, MORE THAN JUST
ABOUT ANY OTHER RACE IN THE
COUNTRY.
NOW, STEFANICK INSISTS SHE
DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT SANTOS'
PATTERN OF DECEPTION UNTIL "THE
NEW YORK TIMES" REVEALED THAT HE
MADE UP STORIES ABOUT HIS PAST,
INCLUDING LIES ABOUT HIS SCHOOL,
JOBS, AND FAMILY HISTORY.
BUT THROUGHOUT THE SANTOS
CAMPAIGN, STEFANICK WAS A
SIGNIFICANT SUPPORTER, AND WE
SPOKE TO SEVERAL PEOPLE WHO
DONATED TO SANTOS'S CAMPAIGN,
INCLUDING ONE MAN WHO GAVE TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS, WHO
SAID STEFANICK'S SUPPORT
INFLUENCED THEM TO DONATE.
THEY WOULDN'T HAVE WITHOUT
STEFANICK.
STEFANICK ENDORSED SANTOS EARLY
IN HIS CAMPAIGN, MORE THAN A
YEAR BEFORE THE ELECTION, AND
HER TWEET INCLUDED A LINK TO A
FUND-RAISING PAGE THAT WOULD
BENEFIT BOTH HER AND SANTOS.
AND SHE LATER TWEET THAT A LUNCH
EVENT RAISED OVER 100,000 TO
HELP GEORGE FLIP NEW YORK
DISTRICT THREE, AS YOU SEE.
ONE DONOR WHO WAS AT THAT LUNCH
TOLD CNN THAT THE ONLY REASON
THEY DONATED WAS BECAUSE OF
STEFANICK, AND SANTOS HIMSELF
UNDERSTOOD THE POWER OF
STEFANICK'S ENDORSEMENT, AS
WELL.
HE USED A PHOTO OF THE TWO OF
THEM AS THE BANNER IMAGE FOR HIS
TWITTER PAGE, UP UNTIL LAST
WEEK.
REPUBLICAN CONSULTANTS SAID THEY
FIRST HEARD OF SANTOS'S ISSUES
IN THE SUMMER OF 2022, BUT IT'S
UNCLEAR HOW MANY SO MANY PROS IN
THE POLITICAL ARENA LET SANTOS
SLIP THROUGH THE CRACKS.
OF COURSE, THOUGH, JIM, THERE
WAS AN INCENTIVE FOR
REPUBLICANS.
THEY WANTED THAT SEAT.
KEVIN McCARTHY, FOR HIS PART,
THEY NEEDED HIS VOTE, RIGHT?
KEVIN McCARTHY, WHO SAID HE
ALWAYS KNEW THERE WERE CONCERNS
WITH HIS RESUME, HOSTED A
FUND-RAISING BREAKFAST FOR HIM.
>> AS YOU SAY, THEY KNEW OR AT
LEAST GOT SIGNALS ABOUT THIS
MONTHS BEFORE THE ELECTION.
>> YEAH.
>> AND I GUESS, YOU KNOW,
PAMELA, THE CONCERN TOO HERE IS,
SHE'S A VERY POWERFUL NEW YORK
REPUBLICAN, AS WE KNOW.
ELISE STEFANICK HAS ENDORSED A
NUMBER OF CANDIDATES.
THIS ONE, THOUGH, UNDERSTANDABLY
DIFFERENT BECAUSE OF WHAT
APPEARED TO BE SO MANY RED FLAGS
THAT WERE MISSED.
>> EXACTLY.
SO MANY RED FLAGS AND I THINK,
ALSO, I MEAN, SHE WAS INVOLVED
IN A LOT OF DIFFERENT RACES, BUT
IN THIS CASE, SHE DIDN'T JUST
ENDORSE AND HELP FUND-RAISER FOR
SANTOS, ACCORDING TO THE SOURCES
THAT WE'VE BEEN SPEAKING WITH.
ONE OF HER TOP AIDS WAS ACTUALLY
ADVISING HIS CAMPAIGN.
WE SHOULD NOTE, THERE'S NO
RECORD, IT WAS IN AN OFFICIAL
CAPACITY, BUT WE'RE TOLD HE EVEN
HELPED SANTOS HIRE PEOPLE.
SO WHEN WE ASKED STEFANICK FOR
COMMENT, HER SPOKESPERSON SAID,
NO ONE FROM HER TEAM WORKED OR
ADVISED SANTOS, AND HE SENT HIM
THIS STATEMENT THAT READS IN
PART, CONGRESSWOMAN STEFANICK
SUPPORTED ALL GOP NOMINEES AND
TARGETED NEW YORK SEATS JUST
LIKE EVERY OTHER REPUBLICAN NEW
YORK OFFICIAL, AND THE ENTIRE
HOUSE REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP
TEAM.
>> PAMELA BROWN, FASCINATING
STUFF.
THANKS SO MUCH.
>> THANK.
>>> SQUEEZE AND SHAM
THAT IS HOW THE WHITE HOUSE IS
PLANNING TO TARGET 18 USE
REPUBLICANS FROM DISTRICTS WHERE
VOTERS SUPPORTED PRESIDENT BIDEN
OVER FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP IN
2020.
FOR BIDEN AND HOUSE DEMOCRATIC
LEADERS THEY BELIEVE THIS IS THE
PATHWAY TO A MAJORITY IN 2024.
ISAAC JOINS US WITH THIS
REPORTING.
WHAT DID YOU FIND TALKING TO
THESE BIDEN ALLIES, WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALS, PLANNING TO GET THE
DISTRICT BLUE AGAIN.
>> THIS IS THINKING FORWARD TO
NOVEMBER AND HOW THEY CAN OFFER
CAR
CARROTS.
INVITATIONS TO THE PRESIDENT'S
BOX OR THE KENNEDY CENTER.
AND STICKS, FLYING THE PRESIDENT
ON AIR FORCE ONE, ALL OF THIS
WITH THE IDEA THERE'S A SLIM
MAJORITY IN THE HOUSE FOR
REPUBLICANS, THINKING IN THE 18
DISTRICTS BIDEN DID BETTER IN
2020, REPRESENTED BY THE HOUSE
REPUBLICANS NOW, THAT'S THE WAY
TO THE MAJORITY -- BACK TO THE
MAJORITY FOR DEMOCRATS IN
NOVEMBER OF NEXT YEAR.
BUT IT'S ALSO MAYBE A WAY TO
SQUEEZE THOSE REPUBLICANS,
THINKING ABOUT THEIR CONCERNS TO
WORK WITH THE WHITE HOUSE IN THE
WAY THEY WANT TO DO SOME
GOVERNING IN BETWEEN NOW AND
THEN.
>> I THOUGHT THE QUOTE YOU HAVE
IN YOUR STORY FROM MIKE LAWLER,
THAT REPUBLICAN HERE IN NEW
YORK, HE SAID SPEAKING ABOUT THE
EFFORTS FROM THE WHITE HOUSE,
AREN'T THEY GOING TO WORK TO GET
US TO LOSE NEXT NOVEMBER NO
MATTER WHAT?
HOW IS THE WHITE HOUSE VIEWING
THAT?
>> Reporter: THIS IS POLITICS,
WHAT IT IS.
IT'S TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHERE
THE BREAKING POINT IS,
ESSENTIALLY, HOW FAR PEOPLE LIKE
MIKE LAWLER CAN BE PUSHED.
LAWLER IS IN A DISTRICT THAT
SUPPORTED BIDEN BY A HEAVY
MARGIN COMPARED TO THE OTHER
REPUBLICANS IN THE BIDEN
DISTRICTS.
YOU HAVE FIVE OTHER REPUBLICANS
IN NEW YORK, SIX IN CALIFORNIA,
THAT THE WHITE HOUSE AND HOUSE
DEMOCRATS -- OF COURSE ONE OF
THOSE SEATS IS GEORGE SANTOS'
DISTRICT.
THAT DISTRICT WENT FOR BIDEN BY
THE HIGHEST MARGIN OF ONE
REPRESENTED BY A REPUBLICAN.
AND THERE'S A SENSE THAT RACE
COULD BE COMING UP SOON IF
THERE'S A SPECIAL ELECTION FOR
HIS SEAT IF SOMETHING HAPPENS
THERE.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THAT'S GOING
AT THIS POINT.
>> WE'LL SEE HOW THE MAP IS
PLAYING OUT.
GREAT REPORTING, ISAAC.